[Musique]
République c'est l'écosystème
d'innovation concret le groupe Renault
Thalès orange d'associés
maintenant pas loin de deux ans l'idée
c'est de transformer la mobilité à
travers des produits des services très
concrets qui sont développés en grande
partie autour de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines puisque
beaucoup des partenaires que je viens de
citer sont fortement implantés dans ce
dans ce territoire et donc on a lancé
déjà cinq produits cinq services dans
des domaines très variés comme la
cybersécurité comme les bornes de
recharge et aussi comme l'accompagnement
des territoires et en particulier le
territoire de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin sur l'utilisation des
données pour améliorer le service aux
citoyens améliorer le trafic améliorer
l'état des routes etc donc des choses
très concrètes et opérationnelles qui
impactent le territoire
dans les exemples parlant des
réalisations on va lancer là au mois de
septembre une borne de recharge
innovante cette borne de recharge elle
va finalement permettre à ce que la
voiture non seulement consomme de
l'énergie quand on a besoin de se
recharger mais qu'elle l'aide aussi la
maison ou le réseau a passé les pics de
consommation c'est ce qu'on appelle une
borne bidirectionnelle et finalement ça
va non pas faire que le véhicule
électrique soit un problème pour le
réseau au contraire une solution pour
aider à la stabilisation du réseau ça
c'est un exemple très concret le
deuxième c'est celui qui a pas
directement les territoires comme
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous avez tous
vu sur les routes des câbles noirs qui
comptent les voitures mesure leur
vitesse aujourd'hui à travers des
données anonymisées des voitures des
cartes SIM des téléphones qui se
déplacent d'orange et bien on arrive
très simplement à avoir accès à ces
données de manière très flexible très
rapide et pour permettre à la
collectivité et bien de réagir pour
organiser au mieux le transport
vis-à-vis des citoyens et dans des coûts
plus maîtrisés possible et on a aussi
d'assosystème qui vient permettre
derrière d'avoir des outils de
simulation et planification de ces
transports grâce à ces données donc on
voit qu'on passe dans la mobilité 2.0
avec Sauvet public
toutes ces actions concrètes elles se
déploie au cours de l'année 2023 sur le
terrain et puis on a plein de nouveaux
projets de nouveaux business de nouveaux
services qu'on fera ravis de vous
présenter et en avant-première je peux
vous dire que je vous donne rendez-vous
le 14 juin à l'ivèque ou nous aurons
plein plein de choses très sympa en très
ancrés sur le territoire à vous montrer
à tous
[Musique]